this is a production of Cornell
University
alright well it's such a nice spring day
out there and so I want to reward you
for staying inside with me with some
beautiful spring flowers I'm going to
talk about wrote a rhododendron project
that I've been working on it's been a
long term project but that's what he
plans for you they tend to be long term
the title is just meant to convey my
effort to really rejuvenate a plant
which has been popular for a long time
in gardens but has sort of languished in
commerce and sort of has lost popularity
in the public imagination it's not for
lack of aesthetics it's an incredibly
beautiful plant and every new variety
that comes out seems more stunning than
the one before the difficulty the
problem really lies with the culture of
the plant its biology it's very
difficult to grow unless you're a you
know willing to a knowledgeable gardener
that's willing to make the effort to do
so so for really the vast majority of
the gardening public these are plants
that fail in the garden we call them in
our cynical moments biennials you buy
them in bloom at the garden center and
they die the next year well our depart
research department of Holden ours is
consists of four principal investigators
so why this big investment and
rhododendrons well part of that is
because of really it's happenstance it's
a convergence of like-minded people with
the same interests able to pool their
resources and and create what became the
David G leech Research Station so david
leitch was a influential American
horticulturist president American Road
intern Society for many years involved
heavily with a garden Conservancy but
also a passionate admirer of
rhododendrons and world a world
authority really he wrote his seminal
book called rhododendrons of the world
which really came out in the early 60s
we helped popularize the plant in the
American consciousness and his niche is
a hybrid Iser was cold hardy hybrids so
his target for hardiness was zone 5 and
in ornamental plants the hardiness is
usually given for the buds the flower
buds that's the trade of interest so
buds Hardy to about minus 15 Fahrenheit
was was his threshold level and he
created these beautiful hybrids here the
red sea and the yellow Capistrano which
are plants the recombinant plants you
don't find those colors in a hardy
background in nature they're created by
hybridizing different species the other
answer to why rotor Denton's is why not
they really are probably the most one of
the most ornamental woody shrubs
available in terms of the diversity of
colors these are species most of them
from Asia showing the range of colors
everything except maybe a blue variety
of types of inflorescence inflorescences
tremendous variability in leaf
morphology this is you have low
elevation tree species with leaves that
are three feet long up to small tiny
little small leaved alpine plants at
about 18,000 feet in the Asian mountains
oftentimes they'll have these kind of
fuzzy undersides here different colors
that's a it's kind of a suede type
covering called India mentum don't
really know the function of it but it's
it's highly ornamental
so what I've been showing you so far is
just a slice of the total genus
rhododendron which worldwide consists of
about a thousand species and that
includes other sub genre which are such
as the deciduous azaleas and the
Evergreen azaleas and the small leaf
coated entrance sub gina's hyman anthes
which is the focus of my talk are the
non scaly leaf largely rhododendrons
most of them evergreen and the center of
diversity center of origin for this
genus is southwest china into the
Himalayas so those solid and hatched
areas areas of extreme topographical
relief which led to a quite rapid
speciation and then outward from that
center you'll find instances of other
species into korea japan central asia
and europe and across the land bridge
into north america so there are a couple
species on the in the eastern mountains
of North America that are very useful
for breeding cold hardiness so breeders
like David would typically take a hardy
North American species and cross it with
a more colorful but less Hardy Asian
species and as a rule you can enter
cross quite freely at the sub generic
level and so there's really no don't
have to go to extremes so to try to for
these wide crosses and the offspring
themselves are often fertile so
hybridize errs would just cross species
with species and oftentimes some of the
modern varieties have as many as a dozen
different species in their background
well you don't find rhododendrons as in
these continental areas of Asia or the
u.s. such as Cleveland and that's the
areas where as extreme heat and cold
Lord owners like higher elevations and
the mountains
or along maritime climate switch are
more buffered in terms of temperature
alright well briefly the interest in the
west and rhododendrons really evolved
out of that crazy Victorian passion for
plants a lot of the collections initial
collections coming into the into the
West were in in England sponsored by
landed gentry who could fund expeditions
and in return they would get seed so
really the from the get-go the interest
was among hobbyist enthusiasts and that
has really continued into today's where
most of the breeders are just what i
call backyard breeders i'm definitely an
exception to the rule and some of the
first hybrids were made in England the
Earl of Carnarvon created some of the
first road in turn hybrids and he was
the owner of what's called high high
crest castle which you know as down
Abbey there you go alright so 20 you
know a century and a half later there
are over 25,000 registered hybrids not
uncommon in popular plants like collect
roses
ok
the style of reading was was done as
pedigree breeding just like dogs and
horses breeders had their favorite stud
plans to use very limited trialing most
things were introduced commercially
based on one plan at one location and
the emphasis really was on flowers above
all and less on performance and
adaptability and that's been a problem
in terms of general public use of these
plants particularly soil issues the
requirement for acid soils ph optimal
around five and very good drainage is
required and that primarily has to do
with avoidance of root rot disease and
so many rhododendrons that are planted
by gardeners who are not knowledgeable
buying them at big-box stores and just
sticking him into the foundation next to
their downspouts involves improper site
selection and lack of proper soil
amendment to try to overcome those those
restrictions so really out of that
25,000 group of named hybrids there's
fewer than 20 that are important
commercially on a national have a
national sales presence those are the
so-called ironclad rhododendrons which
were developed over a century ago in
England but have proven to be very
versatile and so my goal really is to
try to expand that or mental palate and
create really the modern ironclads so
I'm taking a collection that david
leitch created really a 50-year body of
work that he did that developed these
highly ornamental cold hardy plants and
we're adding traits like root rot
disease resistance and heat tolerance to
those with a goal of getting a plant
product that people can grow more
successfully also one particularly with
the addition of heat taunts that will
broaden the market rhododendrons
typically stayed out of culture as you
go south around mason-dixon line
and as you go south the emphasis shifts
to evergreen and deciduous azaleas so
rhododendrons are not considered to be
particularly heat tall and disease
resistance and heat tolerance are not
really coincidental traits our source of
resistance that we're using happens also
to be quite heat tolerant and we feel
that there's probably a functional
relationship between these two working
hypothesis and the breeding program is
that disease resistance is important in
warm climates because disease pressure
increases as you get warmer and wetter
so the disease root rot disease is
caused main causal organism is fight
after cinimon I which I will sometimes
refer to as a fungus but truly it's not
a true fungus it's fungus like some now
classified in the Proteas des that's a
soil pathogen when it finds a
susceptible host colonizes right behind
the root cap and then begins to grow
through the root system eventually movie
up to the crown region you can see this
section here the necrotic regions at
that point it's really disrupting the
vascular system of the plant and you see
this will symptom that's the classic
indication it in the shoots and that's a
reversible at that point the plants as
good as dead if the ZOA spores are the
infectious agents shown here in the
lower right and they are motile they
have flagella they can move a little bit
around in the soil and under wet
conditions and so that's one of the
reason why drainage is so important as a
disease avoidance mechanism
well if I top there is a problem for
rhododendrons and many other crops
because it's a it's a it's a global
invasive it's everywhere and few native
plants like many of our rhododendrons
are resistant so we early on we were
looking for sources of resistance and
when I started there already was a
report done by pathologists at Ohio
State in the mid 70s and so we did
another report in 2002 looking at more
contemporary hybrids just to do screens
and identify either cultivars or species
that would be useful for breeding only
six percent of the hybrids proved
resistant and seventeen percent of the
species out of these collective studies
and that's a that number gets even
smaller when you look for plants that
are not only resistant but also have
some measure of cold hardiness which is
another one of our key criteria so doing
resistant screens is where these are
done in control greenhouse experiments
where we culture the pathogen in the lab
and then make an inoculum and give it to
the plants so we're either doing these
like on the left we're doing
inoculations of single plants and pots
that's when we're usually trying to
identify resistance level and specific
genotypes where we need a replicated
trial or we're looking at seedling
populations breeding populations where
we're screening genetically variable
offspring and these are done when the
plants are at about six months of age
now one of the key metrics that we use
our disease route scores root rot
disease scores which is a numerical
visual rating where scale of one-to-five
so one is a healthy root nice white fine
roots here working up to a level of
intermediate level which is three where
you have necrotic fine roots plus some
of these course roots here are also
damaged and we use pruners to kind of
cut in and respect cross-section as we
go it's a destructive sample up into the
crown rot area and finally five which is
a dead plant so not so it's important
for a parent to be resistant but also
for it to be able to transmit that
resistance to offspring effectively and
not all plants do this equally well it's
based on really breeding value which in
turn is is a measure of heritability the
resemblance that offspring had to their
parents and this is a key thing in woody
plants especially you want a high
heritability value which is estimated on
a scale of 0 to 1 because you want to
make as much gain as possible in one
generation well the generation time and
woody plants can be long if you can get
good product you make good progress in
one generation that's that's really
valuable so based on this is a these are
the parents scores on the scale of one
to five versus offspring on the same
scale and we're looking at open
pollinated offspring of all these
parents and so the heritability estimate
which is narrow sense heritability a
measure of additive genetic variability
is 0 point 8 6 which is satisfactorily
high number this suggests that we can
make pretty good gains in one breeding
cycle
and that value comes in line with some
heritability studies done on other woody
plants mostly these are all threatened
tree species where areas from areas
where my toddler is actually naturalized
and is becoming an ecological issue
eucalyptus Monterey pine European
chestnut so the values they are vary
from point five up to about point eight
six I prunus I don't ultimately through
some trial and error we settled on a
really one species as our foundation for
resistance breeding it's called
rhododendron hypertherm it's native to
Taiwan but it's in it so but it's a high
enough elevation is found between one
and two thousand meters in the central
mountains of Taiwan so it has some
hardiness we can grow it it's probably a
zone six plant we can grow it outside in
Ohio I did survive this winter but it
got took a pretty hard hit but it's
other virtues heat tolerant so this is a
one of the few large leaf evergreen
species that will grow in the Gulf South
in addition to those traits it has good
ornamental traits this compact bushy
growth glossy foliage nice thick thick
leaves and it's very floriferous
although the only comes in white and the
inflorescences or trust as as gardeners
call them are a little bit open but the
typically the standards for something a
little more compact and organized so for
a breeze perspective what we're we're
we're crossing this with plants that we
know have hardiness we have good
saturated colors pinks reds yellows
purples and so forth
so you know breeding experiments and
again these are inoculated greenhouse
studies where we just has just gives you
a visual idea of what comes out of a
cross this is a susceptible cross in
fact most of the parents were crossing
it with our susceptible this is a
variety called Cal SAP open pollinated
so there's about a hundred percent
mortality this is seven weeks after
inoculation cross with the species no
mortality and the f1 shown here there's
a little there are a few dead seedlings
but otherwise things look pretty good so
there's a strong resemblance of of the
first generation to the resistant parent
and you can quantify that just by doing
disease progress plots this is using
another susceptible variety yellow one
called capistrano this is the mortality
rate on the Y over days from inoculation
so this is the open pollinated offspring
from Capistrano a fast trajectory to
extinction r is the hyper ether
resistant parent so it levels off at
about twenty percent mortality among
those seedlings there seems to be some
recombination we're about twenty percent
of the offspring are susceptible rather
than resistant and then the f1 plotted
here which levels off and it tracks
closely to the resistant parent you
measure the area under the disease
progress curves and just subtract and
divide and you can end up with a gain of
in this case eighty-three percent gain
and resistance in one generation
so with some of those breeding
experiments behind us we set off to to
generate large numbers of populations
and progeny and in a in earnest and and
this gives me an idea of how we made
those crosses we bulked different
Hypertherm genotypes we didn't want to
use just one accession because we wanted
to avoid the possibility of inbreeding
depression and later generations and
we'd cross those with an array of
cultivars in this case this is the red
group of varieties we're looking for you
know strong Pink's or reds out of this
cross we also used yellow purple twice
so forth and we grew those out in
quantities with the thought that we
could possibly make some of that first
generation the chair might be worthy of
introduction but then to take that to
the f2 generation through Sid mating
strategies either full or half sib and
this shows the crosses were made in 2005
and 2008 we had them growing out in
field rose they all have kind of the
same look pretty dense this is in the
open Sun they do pretty well you can see
flower buds on them by a year for most
of them had produced flowers to evaluate
and of course they were spending the
winter outside so we're getting a
performance and an ornamental evaluation
within four years by 2009 and here shows
you some of the selections we made out
of those thousands based on ornamental
value and performance so we reasonably
satisfied since one of the parents was
white and we're happy with what we were
seeing in terms of color saturation
often times to you get this nice
patterning gardeners call them blotches
but of course bees know them as
pollination guides
those that we're seeing now name
whoops on this list actually no but I
will finish up with those I'll show you
okay in fact this I'm going to peel off
from the breeding program at this point
and pick it up at the end of the talk
and detour a bit on on some stress
testing we've done so I've been talking
so far really about you know
transferring resistance genes to to
progeny and in pathology the operating
principle is called the disease triangle
I know many of you have probably been
introduced to this so the disease
symptoms we see under in outdoor
conditions is really the interaction
between the host plant the pathogen and
the environment and the environment can
have a huge effect on moderating the
outcomes and typically stress
environmental conditions reduce
resistance that's a phenomena that's
called predisposition so if you look at
abiotic stresses like extremes of
moisture or temperature salinity ozone
those are all things that can somehow
change host physiology in a way that
weakens its defense response and when in
particular I was interested in looking
at flooding and heat because those are
two traits that deal immediately with
our desire to move these plants south
and also with really the heavy kind of
substandard soil conditions you find in
most most landscapes so in 2011 we
conducted a field flooding trial we put
out an array of genotypes some unknowns
as well as some controls both
susceptible and resistant checks and
this was an area where we knew that we
suspected the pathogen was present in
our fields the idea initially was to
flood the area by pumpy and water from
our palm
but it turned out to be the wettest year
on record in Northeast Ohio so mother
nature took over our treatment plant and
we had conditions like shown on the lift
repeatedly throughout the season
probably on seven or eight occasions
where we would we would flood and then
over the course of a day or two they
would drain so by the end of one season
then they were clear you know most
things were looking pretty bad from
outright dead too oftentimes a chlorosis
is a sign of stress of root rot damage
but what really stood out was how well
high tree thrown performed under those
conditions that's shown here so it and
when we did it so we harvested all these
dead plants gots root scores of five and
then we harvested the survivors and
calculated the values for those and this
shows the breakdown we had groups of
susceptible plants resistant benchmarks
three of those resistant plants that
don't have hyper wreaths remenham some
experimental hybrids with unknown
resistance levels and then the species
itself at the bottom and on the left
here this column shows disease scores
under non flooded conditions and these
were determined in previous experiments
before the field trial so you know are
resistant group here and here had roots
values about to which is equivalent to
just damage to find roots but but
nothing further under flooded conditions
some clear changes occurred everything
was more susceptible under stress but in
particular the resistant benchmarks
almost doubled from their root scores so
that's equivalent to from going from
just having fine root damage to damage
up in the crown region so these plants
were nearly dead in contrast hyper
Ephraim although the values went up in
route scores only about 30
and the hybrids of hyper wreath room did
quite well overall they weren't
significantly different from the the
parent species in terms of roots core
values and you know we're attributing
these results not to flooding stress
directly but to pathogens and I mean
hypoxia isn't possibility typically
doesn't lead in to plant mortality and
lure Dennis are can handle about 48
hours of flooding with with no issue
plus the plants really the sequence of
mortality in the field really followed
our expectations based on our benchmarks
so that the susceptible plants died
right away resistant plants held on
longer and then fun to kind of close out
that that question we also isolated
fight opera from necrotic regions of the
field plants and so that's done by in
this case we took the pieces of stem
near the crown region grew them out on
semi selected media which will screen
for phytophthora but not at the genus
level but not at the species level if I
chopped the cinnimon I though does have
kind of an unusual morphology it's coral
like or Coral Lloyd so that's another
indication of a potential match and then
finally we had those samples sent to
Ohio State and they did a sequence
analysis against the there's a
diagnostic storage protein in phytother
cinammon I and the match was 96 two
hundred percent so we're fairly certain
that that really flood the phytother was
was causing the symptoms and that it was
that some of the effects were seeing
were were aided and abetted by by the
flooding treatment so in conclusions
from the flooding trials that it's it's
less predisposed to disease than
the resistant rhododendrons the traits
heritable because the f1's that almost
ed statistically they did as well as the
resistant parent and this is good in the
sense that in terms of a a product
development because we could potentially
develop rhododendrons that can withstand
sub those poor soils heavy soils found
around in home landscapes we also looked
at heat stress and this is another key
question the being that are these plants
that are adapted to warm climates like
hyper Ephraim less predisposed to
disease under high temperature stress
and to do these kinds of experiments we
we we chose a pulse treatment method
where you could expose tissue in this
case roots to heat remove that stress
then inoculate it or and include
inoculated controls and then
subsequently measure the level of
resistance in those treated plants and
we use large water bath which is this
one here to apply heat we grow either
single plants or seedlings and pots and
then drop those pots into a poly bag and
immerse it and water bath for treatment
and our treatment temperatures range
from a room temperature up to about 42
Celsius typically experiment was done
one hour to target in the bath and then
one hour at the target temperature
and these are some data we just got this
winter comparing Asian species for the
response to heat stress and I just have
summary means for these I don't have not
run the stats yet but basically we have
read and so these are root rot scores
plotted against days after inoculation
and we're comparing on the bars the
controls with or without heat but no
phytophthora and then with or without
heat plus phytophthora being the green
bars and the dark green is the heat
treatment so one thing to point out in
the control is is that there's no lethal
effect of this heat stress on the plants
and in this case this is a species from
central asia called panicum it's a
susceptible plant it was really our
control and it we reached almost
complete mortality within a week and a
half of inoculation in both the non
stress and the heat treatment no
surprises there I mean it's hard to make
a very susceptible plant more
susceptible in contrast so we we looked
at two Asian species that are resistant
one from japan called pci which is not
considered to be heat tolerant and then
our feet tall Piper wreath room and in
those cases the heat stress and key ski
I the dark green clearly elevated the
disease scores especially in the early
part of the time course again I don't
have a test yet on significance but it
it looks like it could be and hyper
wreath room except for the very first
sampling date which could be sampling
error all subsequent dates the heat
stress plants showed the same as or
lower root scores than the non stress
one so synthesis yet suggests that
hypertherm is not predisposed
to disease by higher soil temperatures
much in the way that it was less
predisposed by flooding so those are
good two attributes in addition to
resistance per se another study was more
ecological so we wanted to know whether
natural populations are warm adapted
ecotypes more disease tolerant following
heat stress than their cold tolerant
relatives and do this we switched to a
species called rhododendron minus which
is native to the eastern US and it grows
from high elevation north carolina down
to within 50 miles of the Gulf Coast so
in the Florida Panhandle and southern
Alabama for instance and we've been
collecting those over the years putting
together trying to capture the really
arranged wide collection of the species
and we have compared to two populations
so far the one here at elevation 4,000
feet in north carolina and one low
elevation in southern Georgia called
providence canyon so this is the shrub
here at the top of hawksbill mountain
and you'd find the shortly wrote under-
at the bottom of this Canyon along the
riverbed in Providence Canyon so we did
the same kinds of disease progress plots
some kind of heat treatments that I
described earlier temperatures were a
little bit different I'm showing you
results at 26 and at 42 Celsius we also
did them at 34 50 degrees Celsius
looking at the mortality rates over time
so at 26 degrees and the blue is the
northern high elevation population the
red is the southern low and these are
the controls down here so he treated but
not inoculated again there's no heat
treatment appears to be sub-lethal and
it twenty sixth ave they're basically
the same statistically the same response
both species are highly susceptible to
fight opera so there's no mortality with
in almost complete with in under two
weeks from inoculation and that's where
you'd expect that in the case of a
natural population that's being
challenged with an invasive pathogen
it's never seen it before at 42 Celsius
and there's a high degree of mortality
and ultimately in both populations but
the the rate of disease development or
mortality in the southern population is
much slower and looking at areas under
the curve here that turns out to be a
statistically significant difference so
there is a transient effect anyway the
heat stress appears to be initiating
some sort of defense responds in the one
climate ecotypes that's not found in the
cold one so that was a fairly novel
result and we want to see if we can
generalize that those data looking at a
larger sample of populations
still the question of root damage is
there you know it's sub-lethal but you
don't know if there is some something
going on at 42 Celsius that's pretty
warm so we and that could confound the
interpretation of results so we did some
viability assays on both populations
using TTC staining a vital stain that
will turn sells pink as its as its
reduced by mitochondria and you can
elute that stain and you'll measure its
spectrophotometer with a
spectrophotometer so here we're showing
absorbance standardized over dry weight
milligrams dry weight for both southern
low northern high populations and there
is no significant difference in
viability estimated that way so we feel
that at within that 26 242 Celsius
window root Bible design issue and
that's a good range of temperatures to
continue working in at 50 Celsius I
mentioned we had done we had done screen
there and there actually was probably
fifty percent loss of viability in those
tissues a bit too extreme well we don't
really understand and rotor dinners
what's going on at the physiological
level but there are reports there's
increasingly reports from other systems
notably a rabid opsys and tomato of how
predisposition might function and it
really involves sort of antagonistic net
metabolisms so you start with a
resistant plant given it an abiotic
stress that kicks in the hormone
abscisic acid which is commonly it's a
very common upregulated stress-related
hormone but ABA increased a VA can cause
a inhibition of defense signaling
pathways that are specifically those
mediated by jasmonic acid or salicylic
acid
so if there is then a pathogen challenge
during or apt subsequent to that stress
then the defense system of the plant is
lowered and you can change phenotypes
from resistance to susceptible that's
that's kind of a consensus model there's
certainly lots of variations on that and
we know and on what I feel it from my
work since we've identified genotypes
that are less predisposed that clear
there's probably involves some different
regulation at the GE level and with the
advent of less expensive genomic
analyses metabolomics comparative
transcriptome analysis these would be
perhaps fruitful studies for the future
if you were predisposed to that all
right well finally back to the breeding
program since we wanted to develop heat
tolerant Lord of donors the obvious
thing was to put them in a south and see
how they did for this work we found a
industry partner with plant development
services based in near Mobile Alabama
they have a brand called southern living
plant collection which is quite popular
and pjs I really they're not a nursery
per se they work between breeders like
me and the marketplace they take care of
the development aspects of the plant
those are services that we don't have in
house at holder and the test site was in
southern Louisiana independence we put
had put in over 165 selections that we
made in Madison initially and a put out
a replicated field trial the plants were
shaded I think for the first half of the
first summer and subsequently have been
out in the open
and this is now the beginning of year
three of the trial so they get fairly
strong afternoon Sun and based on the
results so far there are really about
twenty percent or maybe thirty out of
the 165 selections that we put in have
really performed well that is where you
know we're at a hundred percent
survivorship and then surviving plants
themselves are vigorous growers they
have good leaf quality and they're
producing good flowers such as the one
shown here and this past March I was
down there while they were in bloom the
first time I had been there in bloom and
we selected 34 introduction those are
the ones shown here so two Pink's one
kind of a clear pink the other more of a
rose pink some of these patterns these
flares and blotches this one has a
frilled margin to the pedal as does this
there's another nice feature where the
pedals the backs of the pedals would be
darkly pigmented and the face will be
lighter so that creates kind of a
bicolor effect and these little nuances
do make a difference it makes the plant
fancier and we're going to we hope that
these can compete with what's already
kind of been established as the current
standard for rhododendrons and of course
in the South they will have no
competition because there are no
rhododendrons yet that have been
developed
so these will go into tissue culture one
this one already is and then
subsequently out to growers we can glean
some extra information from that field
trial by we want to do to confirm the
presence of Phi top there just as we did
in Madison Ohio by isolating and
sequencing the pathogen just to prove
that that's what's causing it it is an
old nursery site and they apparently
grew a lot of azaleas and camellias
there and those are both hosts for
phytophthora and because nurseries are
constantly moving plants in and out of
their inventory and fight optic travels
in soil it's quite likely that it's
there all the certainly the symptoms are
consistent with it and then it would be
good to go back and look at both the top
and bottom classes of performers now we
have the original mother plants still in
ohio and so we can go back to them and
do test for resistance under control
conditions and confirm that they are
respectively resistant or susceptible
and that will really close the circle on
this notion that disease resistance is
is a key trait to surviving in a warm
climate like that with high disease
pressure well home we always talk about
being about more than just a pretty
plant because we're a serious
institution on a serious mission but the
and so I even though the scope of my
project is fairly narrow I've tried to
move it in a direction that's topical
that addresses the issues that you know
knowledgeable scientists are concerned
about in these days and age and so the
issue of sustainability is addressed
because resistance will allow probably
result in reduced pesticide use
typically fungicide drenches that are
used in nurseries-plants are broadly
adaptable I think my goal of covering
zones five to nine is
probably been modified by the past two
winners and I think we will release
these marketed to zone six to nine
although you can you know many zone five
winners it will do fine just as it has
done well in Ohio up until recently
we'll call them climate change ready
certainly there they're positioned for
global warming and warming is not just
an issue in terms of stress on plants
but most predictions state that disease
pressure will also increase under those
conditions and there's an increased
chance with warmer climates that
pathogens like phytother eliza in our
northern forests and finally it's a good
example of a you know solution based use
of biodiversity showing how we can tap a
species like pipe wreath room to address
a real stubborn problematic issue like
root rot disease finally I just like to
thank like some of my staff Jing Wang is
a research associate who works
year-round with me and Hillary right has
been a seasonal one of our volunteers
Susan Hannah and my collaboration with
PD SI is through buddy lee shown here on
the right who's the director of plant
innovations for pds I and also an
accomplished ornamental breeder in his
own right and finally a few sources of
funding not to mention our by major
underwriter which is the Holden
Arboretum
that's your national a name and license
everything for years you have to prevent
we're those selected worse
yeah water they were i but there's some
structure those they are I didn't Patti
hi Bri that last one started my
collection but there's a outfit on the
west coast called support and species
they have pretty good world collection
including several reasons so they made
some process those session paris that in
7c and then I screen that the resistance
the survivors that we didn't know about
their flower activities
time is selected
most is part of a person something we
have Marshall dollars with maybe more
substance
hours
we're leaving our rooms right
now they're not known for sure they're
green turn around
this doesn't ask if you have
No
it said it's fine tuning
so it's probably
phyto accents
we think there's a major sponsor I
didn't show that discuss another parent
loading plotted the offspring scores
worth the whole they had shifted up more
susceptible appearances a group of us
were measured since
that some of you may be right I wouldn't
know
each at Hector
j bathroom names i have what's the way
humanity sort of carrie has been we're
going down there sugar well I think it's
a lot of it committee so out of my hands
I think PS i will probably
and there really are the marketeers if
you can do a lot of that in a sense
quite add to that discussions but we
sort of have another thing sort of to
like all these plastic baggies awareness
go sleepy for the south
I think we're out of time but again I
want to thank you Steve for traveling to
its good and sharing your research with
us this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu